luis heal is back he is needed right now
too i mean we haven't seen him in a
little bit history interrupted i mean i
don't know there's a lot of different
things you can look at he hasn't given
up an earned run and his three starts
and that one is tipped into the glove of
sanchez dickerson down swinging so
guerrero walks two straight walks issued
by heal so here's beau bechet
high fly ball left field
gallow had a misstep but recovered to
make the play and here is otay oscar
hernandez to face louis hill first and
second two men out just underway here at
the stadium yankees and blue jays struck
him out swinging slider away so two
strikeouts and two walks alec manuel is
going to try and keep that going for the
blue jays there are his numbers in 15
starts five and two are very good 363
earned on average 88 punch outs in 79 in
a third inning and the yankees have
runners on the corners with two outs for
le mayhew
and there's a liner into right right to
the oscars so
no harm no foul so we go to the second
inning as alejandro kirk will face luis
heal
and he waves at that slider one away
three strikeouts for heal
gorielle he's seventh in the order
there's 93 runs about it here's a 3-2
struck him out swinging slider away
three strikeouts in a row four for the
game for heel
and with two-way here is jake lamb the
2-2
struck him out swinging fast while up he
struck out the side he has struck out
four in a row
sanchez with 20 home runs
1-0 so we had a ground ball down to
third cut up in the hole by lamb goes to
second for one turn to first
just in time wow i wasn't sure they were
going to get them too bad now for rugnet
or door high fly ball out to right field
hernandez with his heels on the warning
track makes the catch to retire odor and
the side bases loaded one man out for
beau bashette
right back to heal drops
gets the force at home the drop cost him
the double play but he had the presence
of mind to fire home and get the second
out basis is still loaded but now there
are two outs here's t oscar hernandez he
struck out in the first inning three two
swinging in the miss he got him
and is he pumped up
so heal pitches in and out of trouble no
score as we go into the bottom of the
third 9-1-2 against alec manoa strike
three late call by the home plate umpire
edwin muscoso but it's a strikeout
great pitch
now two-seam fastball on the inside
quarter and gunman is caught looking
back-to-back strikeouts for manila here
in the third
there's a good slider he got it where he
wanted it that time
and judge
and that's walk number seven three walks
in this inning to load the bases
well aaron boone has to make the call to
the bullpen six strikeouts seven walks
lucas litki comes in to make his 52nd
appearance of the season and he'll face
the left-handed battering cory dickerson
with the bases loaded
bounce to the plate and that gets away
from sanchez guerrielle's racing up the
line the throw goes towards the plate
and got away from the pitcher it's
backed up by rizzo the first baseman as
toronto scores and takes a one-nothing
lead runners go back at second and third
for marcus simeon
and there it is he stays on it and
drives it to left field one runs in here
comes danny jansen and marcus
he's out at second
and he runs into an out but the blue
jays get three runs marcos simeon comes
through with two more rbis
first and second one out and that will
bring up
alejandro kirk
chops slowly to third
nice slick play by odor made the play
got his foot on the back for the force
so here is lourdes goriel jr
and he struck him out swing on a
breaking ball
sanchez has to throw to first with the
2-3 put out gary sanchez hit into a
5-4-3 double play back in the second
inning
to high fastball jansen over near the
dugout he's got room and makes the catch
oh andrew velazquez comes up in a big
spot first and second one man out for
the number nine hitter
high fastball does the trick that's the
third strikeout for manoa so big spot
here for the veteran gardener the only
player in the yankee roster that
actually played on the yankees when
derek jeter was still active the runners
go 3-2
deep to right field there it goes
see ya a game-tying three-run home run
by the veteran
brett gardner they needed a big blast
and he just gave it to him to tie the
game
tell you what the yankees needed a big
hit and they just got it now you got to
continue to fight no you got back in
this game
absolutely sleepwalking offensively the
last three days but boy a huge hit for
brett gardner and now they go righty on
riding with gary sanchez sanchez
is over six against
garrett richards
[Applause]
change up and he got him
well what a pitch by trevor richards the
yankees will leave two more
go ahead run a second here's guerrero
swinging in the missy got him filthy
sinker
has guerrero down on strikes
the one-two
grounded up the middle right there is
lemayo
moving to third
is simeon two men out we're in the
seventh tied three three holmes is a
ground ball machine the one oh and he
got one on the ground and it rolls
through the right side a base hit
in to score simeon and toronto's in
front for three
trevor richards stays in the game
brunetto
good change up ass hodor
swings and misses one out one on back to
the top of the order and brett gardner
change up [ __ ] knocks it down goes to
second and it was a bad throw all
they'll get
is that lead runner gardner at second
judge at first with an infield single
the pitch swinging a miss he got him on
strikes chased a fastball away a chance
to score nobody out a runner at third
base the left-handed batting jake lamb
stepping in gerard dyson is the pitcher
under the third and lamb goes after the
first pitch this is pretty deep judges
got a good arm sets up tagging at third
is dyson here comes the play at the
plate not in time
gerard dyson scores up standing as he
steps right past gary sanchez
but jake lamb will be credited with the
sacrifice fly
five three as the movies are set to mat
in the ninth and they'll face the oldest
chapman vladi is one for three with walk
he's also struck out
all right he hits it hard to left field
and this one's gonna go how about number
41. for vladi guerrero
and that'll give him 99 rbis on the
season a line shot into the seats in
left boy what a thing of beauty
that was
114 miles an hour off the bat
a big run here in the ninth
six three now the barking from the
yankee bench has been ongoing for a
while looks like that might be matt
blake looks like he don't know if he's
thrown out looks like he's heading down
the tunnel well he's thrown out for sure
the frustration is bubbling over
left-handed hitter at the plate
is a slider hit in the air out to deep
center field dyson going back he reaches
out he slides and he makes the catch to
finish the ball game gerard dyson laying
out with a backhanded grab
and deep left center field reeling it in
to preserve the 6-3 victory for the
toronto blue jays